here in the southeastern United States
these besieged plants have actually sent
up a chemical mist an SOS to these black
wasps why because black wasps are known
as a food coloring and some aphids are
busily sucking the life out of these
plants now despite its nickname this
Watts isn't here merely to kill the
aphids no that would be too easy
like a character in a James Bond movie
the wasp has a more exquisite to
punishment for the eight with a clinical
precision the wasp injects a single egg
into each a pods body this means a slow
death for the AVA as the wasp egg grows
inside it each wasp can plant eggs in
200 even's the aphids send out their own
chemical alarm systems and the colony
panics but it's too late the wasp has
done its work hasta la vista baby and we
mean baby the aphids face a gruesome
death the ravenous wasp larvae will eat
the aphid alive from the inside out
the aphids body becomes the incubator
for the young of its predator a new
generation of assassins will soon emerge
littering these killing fields with
corpses okay now here's the money shot
the young wasp emerging to seek out more
aphids to begin this cycle all over
again the wasp with its exquisitely
deftly planned and yet just doing what
nature is programmed it to do